julie raimu et chloé c'est tout jeune
courtisans seront nos guides dans cette
promenade et senteurs une traversée des
siècles pour découvrir les parfums des
anciens rois
eh bien nous verrons là encore que les
parfums en fonction des époques et des
rois des reines servait mais pas
seulement qu'à sentir beau en quarts
loin des idées reçues au moyen-âge les
rois santé beau à votre avis combien de
bains va prendre notre reine à cette
période par semaine par mois par an 1
par quoi un par jour maya en reine du
16e siècle se laver chaque jour pendant
trois heures avec des essences poivrer
ben y avait on était assez propre et que
le parfum ça se faisait pas trop comme
mode hearst c'est pour se protéger des
maladies il des parfums pour se protéger
des maladies des odeurs qui s'évapore
avec le temps car au xviie siècle
ils ne se lavent plus par peur d'être
malade justement c'est en fait on se
rend compte que l'eau chaude
c'est un garde salle ouvre un petit peu
ces trous sur la peau et le docteur il a
peur que toutes les maladies qu'ils
trouvent dans l'air et ce qu'elle aime
faire ces maladies à vendre est rentré
dans votre corps à cause des petits
trous la tour ont été dilater par l'eau
chaude
c'est vraiment une découverte au travers
l'histoire et à travers le temps d'une
manière un peu plus ludique que
d'ordinaire qui permet aussi de faire
participer des enfants qui jouent leur
propre rôle
pour ce que tu as appris sur la reine du
xviie siècle que seul avait plus trop à
cette époque
et qu'on sentait plutôt mauvais un
voyage dans le temps au pays des odeurs
et de la toilette royal l'occasion de
connaître un après-midi la vie de
château pouvait s'asseoir pour